south carolina senator lindsey graham
senator i'm alarmed by the series of
events we've seen a lot together you
more than me a little bit older but this
is a challenge what role does the
economy have to do with confronting
china
it has a lot okay we're you know our
supply chain medically we learned here
in covid was china-centric a lot of the
pharmaceuticals being developed in china
we needed to fight covet so let's break
that chips we just passed a big chips
bill uh whether you make a refrigerator
television or f-35 most of the chips are
made in taiwan why does taiwan matter
ninety percent of the high-end chip
manufacturing in the world is done in
taiwan the last thing you want china to
do is to take over taiwan have a
monopoly in the 21st century chip market
so here's the deal
china is flexing their muscles because
binds administration is dumb and weak
every time putin threatened utrain we
got weak instead of imposing sanctions
when he built up his army on the border
we we didn't want to provoke him instead
of flowing in weapons to the ukraine
before the invasion we didn't want to
provoke uh putin so what are we doing in
taiwan i have legislation with bob
mendinde as a democrat the chairman of
the foreign relations committee to give
more economic aid to taiwan more
military assistance to taiwan and the
administration the bite administration
is working to kill the bill
senator i understand taiwan in the past
has been reluctant to accept a lot of
our military aid because they didn't
want to provoke their their goliath
neighbor is that correct and number two
have they changed their stance
well 63 f-16s to be made in south
carolina
or to go to taiwan we have a supply
problem everything in america is broken
and if we pass this bill the mansion
schumer bill inflation goes up not down
the supply chain is broken so the
taiwanese are ready to fight for their
freedom it would be tough to invade that
island and you see the ukrainians you
see what happens when people taste
freedom they're going to fight like
tigers not to give it up so more f-16s
to taiwan more economic support in the
bill with senator menendez we put
sanctions on china when they cyber
attack the democracy in taiwan this is a
strong statement against china and the
biden administration is undercutting our
efforts the biden administration is in
denial about the rise of radical islam
in afghanistan we killed zhawa harry
that's a good thing but he was out in
the open living in the house of the
number two taliban commander you have a
broken border how easy would it be for
terrorists from afghanistan to come
through the southern border and kill a
bunch of us
true
uh i want you to hear chris ray i'm a
little disappointed in him almost every
step of the way i know he likes to keep
his power to dry and understate
everything even dick cheney said pick up
your energy a little uh here's what
chris ray said about china
director ray who is the most significant
geopolitical foe the united states faces
in the next decade
that would be the people's republic of
china and specifically the chinese
communist party it's the hacking it's
the college students it's the spies
amongst us they're trying to get into
the fed we have to get them on their
heels center dude is there a plan in
place
to start comprehensively identifying
them as are not strategic but in every
facet are full
well you know the fbi director said
every 12 hours they open up a case
against chinese espionage the biggest
cyber threat comes from china we're not
responding in kind all i can say is that
the border is completely broken it's not
secure this bill we're going to vote on
here in the
day or so will not reduce inflation
there is no plan to secure our border in
the threat of rising terrorism and we
don't have enough resources to push back
against chinese cyber attacks
and and economic espionage according to
director ray when it comes to domestic
growth and prosperity the body
administration's killing job growth when
it comes to foreign threats they're weak
and dumb
i wish you were wrong but you're not i
also think you got to go to wall street
and you got to tell them listen i don't
care what you can make over there i
don't care how cheap it is to go over
there time to take that manufacturing
put it in central america let's attack
both problems at once and let them build
no one's been to more afghanistan as a
lawmaker more than you and then zawahiri
gets blown up on a balcony in kabul do
you think he was traveling alone senator
no i don't think we got the only al
qaeda guy in in afghanistan i applaud
the killing of this guy because he
helped plan 9 11. but it should be a
wake-up call he was living in a house
owned by the number two guy in the
taliban government openly in kabul so
clearly the relationship is back again
before 9 11
the taliban allowed al qaeda to roam
freely in afghanistan that's what led to
9 11. now 21 years later the taliban are
in a relationship with uh al qaeda yet
again training camps are rising and the
border is completely broken there's a uh
this is a perfect storm for another 911
and the biden administration in my view
is not taking any corrective action and
this bill again we're going to vote on
is going to make our inflation problems
worse
the border is not secure the taliban
knew about zarihiri and this inflation
reduction act is a line of fraud we just
got to get to november uh
yeah we'll see if we can get there uh
senator lindsey graham always great
thank you sir hey sean hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else